what up reject nation we are here today
to watch moon night episode press ladies
and gentlemen we got koi zhandra with us
back follow him on tick tock for a whole
bunch of videos he does about all kinds
of things it's great stuff right koi
it's great stuff long form youtube short
form tik tok yeah hey hey guys full
length watch long as we sync up with the
time code for moon i aware john they're
over at our patreon page go over there
sync up with the time code we also got a
bunch of other shows thanks to everyone
who's become a superject it means a ton
but if you can't do that at least leave
a like that helps us out in the
algorithm and leave your thoughts down
below what you thought about this
episode lastly we should thank who we
should thank the boys at prepper for
editing down the highlights all right
guys i think we're ready to hop into
this aren't we caught so three very
excited all right i've included both of
you you guys happy i feel incredibly
happy
shut up
[Music]
and then i i found him with the scarab
living 20 minutes from our old place
he's probably going to get himself
killed running around cairo
that's why you look so unhappy to be
going home
i love her hair bootleg passport factory
more company let you teach you how to do
all of this the man indulged you you
think his dig sites were any place for a
child archaeology one big mess of
obsessive bookworm i just put together
who she is in what sense we'll talk
later okay
call me sentimental
but i worry about you
have a good trip love
what a great scene
hope we see her again for comic readers
i think she might be the daughter of the
scientist who was digging up that
bushmaster kills in the comments oh
that's interesting i like that yeah
we've all we've all read there
let me consult john he's a common expert
and if you're already watching this you
already seen the episodes they might
have already clarified that just the
theory
here
i'll expect isn't cairo
is tracking us
i know
she's here
all it took was a white man a fighter
a white man with a compass of gold
we get [ __ ] done guys you're never gonna
find hero really
[Music]
oh wow
oh
okay dancing we're fighting we're gonna
do
[Music]
keep conquer's name
[Laughter]
i love the difference in physicality
between the two
i know it's time to taunt i seen this
guy before mark
[Music]
don't do it mark
[Music]
oh that is so awesome so we stay with
our one lead well i'm alive
where are you taking me
you are the airport
he said why are you acting like a
foreigner yeah because stephen could
speak the language or was it jake for a
minute let me talk to you for a second
just avoid all mirrors mark
real born identity vibe to this
absolutely
the mark identity
[Music]
we need the info
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god stephen what did you do i
swear that wasn't me
where's it
take him to the ledge
he's just a kid
he'll talk jake locklear is a cab driver
in egypt
he speaks the language
[Music]
okay
oh
yep damn
you could have stopped him mark you got
guts kid
the signal for an audience with the gods
is to risk their wrath
but what's the worst that could happen
anger them enough
and they'll imprison me in stone
you have any good ideas ever
i have a bad one
can't you i've got some hero's head off
could you eat mr harold
what are you doing
no sending the guns a signal they can't
ignore he clips it
get a way to make the news
[Music]
our case against arrow must be
indisputable
aren't you coming with
oh i'll be there
a lot of interesting use of waters here
mm-hmm and the conscious appearing very
like disorientingly you've been banished
once for nearly exposing us honshu but
manipulate the sky again and we will
imprison you in stone
bear me your self-righteous threat
we simply trust our avatars to carry out
our purposes without calling undue
attention to ourselves not like some of
us avatars are not enough
that's so good speak your purpose i call
for judgment against arthur harrow
with charges
conspiracy to release amit
that's a heavy accusation
[Music]
just go a few miles if i just just look
left
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
as i see by the presence of conscious
current
makeshift avatar
of our meeting must be nefarious you
know exactly why we are here
this is a man
who literally does not know his own name
i have no idea how many personalities he
must possess the man is clearly insane
whoa
we will not
tolerate violence
in this chamber
we'll just let it happen outside are you
unwell
oh no oh stephen grant this is about how
dangerous he is if you would just listen
for a second he has committed no offense
this matter is concluded check his
tattoo out i feel like we just watched
like a 10-minute tragic play in a
shakespearean set yeah exactly
a majority named senfo he was tasked
with recording the location of the tomb
in case the gods ever changed their
minds and decided to show mercy
his sarcophagus was stolen and sold on
the black market you might want to start
there maybe it's back at the
fast-forward episode how are you doing
here you should be here why because my
name pisses off a few people in cairo
who cares
it's not the locals that i'm worried
about
come with me
i'll help you find what you need kind of
a creep caught you a little bit
just so you know i'm not here to help
you i'm here for me and for everyone
else who have died of horror success if
they get back together is it a
polyamorous relationship yeah
multiple personalities don't you do
anything
you do anything with stephen i'm a no
ah egyptian red fair
everyone loves a good joust right this
way thank you
marvel's the knights i'm looking forward
to seeing you after madrid i'm sure you
two will have a lot to tell magikarp
yes
they mentioned something we know
references
no he gets private lessons by the best
in his backyard
oh god this is my husband brufino
yes
meet you
[Laughter]
why such interest in senpu in particular
oh actually our purchases sorry i'd like
to hear from your husband if you don't
mind but i think i just would love to
take a look
feel free
great
yeah
okay rodrigo santoro is an [ __ ]
there's no location indicates it
because the information has to be
unlocked
it's
coded okay
will you give me a minute i just i gotta
talk to stephen just
he just needs a couple of minutes in
there alone
he's
he's
he's praying
like this yeah
now if you match those stars up with the
other piece over there and put it all
together it should make a starch hey
what are you doing whoa
[Music]
that's interesting it appears we have a
concerned third party yeah
get up
of course that's an [ __ ] you keep
thinking that distance will prevent the
wounds from your father's murder from
reopening your husband doesn't tell you
the truth you don't tell her because you
know that if you do
she'll see you exactly as you see
yourself
what are you waiting for
he's gone
where is he
[Music]
here comes moon cape
nice
buy me some time back in
whoa
nice work
[Music]
let him do his thing
awesome
give me the body mark
oh
that's cool
that's it timeout guys let's all calm
down yeah we're all worked up let's all
just not chill that f out and talk for a
second
[Music]
[Music]
boy
nice
[Music]
i love the companion pieces to his moons
[Music]
for love
[Music]
into the mist there are parts of us
fighting there might be a bet afflicts
batman acrobatics and brutal like punch
downs what was harrah talking about
what do you mean
he said i had a right to know i have no
idea
i have herpes i think he killed her dad
we need stephen he understands all of
this i really think it's worth giving
him a shot
i summon the guards you summon the worm
it's okay just let go i don't have time
you might need that mirror well now he
needs it for mirror purposes
all right go ahead you're in
cheers thanks a lot
cool nice master class with oscar is
[ __ ] incredible they came up with a
way to get about using the sun and the
stars
it's french
[Laughter]
oh my god she's falling for him we
should be able to triangulate the stars
into coordinates right unless we know
exactly what the sky looked like on that
date we're buggered i remember that
night
ah
i was the one who made james cameron
change the titanic stars he would have
fit on that door though it will come at
a cost and i cannot do it alone are you
gonna get trapped in stone for that i
mean it's kind of a big deal do what i
do
the tva is not gonna be happy about this
[Music]
wow
wow
before all that pollution
[Music]
[Music]
great transition
i don't know how much longer i can do
this
can't you
and in the end
he left us no choice
he's tethered to this place
you saw culture
how's it feel i'm going to do what you
could not
then when it's finished
i want you to remember one thing
your torment forged me
i owe my victory to you goddamn wow hell
yeah
i want a
dense episode there was so much death
dense are we talking about eternals whoa
guys i mean there was a lot of
non-interference from the gods so we
could be
it's true are we still doing your credit
joke and we're not doing the credit show
we gotta do the credit show i do like
that they change up the credits yeah
every episode and they also change up
the music too i'm really curious we're
getting jake now that we have a
mysterious third identity do you think
you can buy a little conscious statue
within a week oh yeah that's coming
merch
i also like that mr knight is now
just representative of the other
identities moon knight they can kind of
play with that to make him less of a
wasn't a punchline but it was a joke in
how he was used and now they can evolve
that and that's what i was hoping they'd
do with them well just in that moment
alone steven's necessity really came
into the fold this time yeah and mr
knight was a necessity because the
control i don't think there's a
post-credits scene probably my
post-credit scene but we should wait
efficiency
okay well
did you guys like it
i liked it
i had a great time part of me was a
little worried that maybe we would get
into the middle and it would start to
sag but it did not it had one of the
crazier fight scenes i think we've seen
in a disney plus show many stabbings i
also was a little worried that it was
moving at such a fever pace at the top
that
this the sag metaphor solid i don't know
if it would if i'd get exhausted by it
like i was worried it would either dip
or it'd be overwhelming like too much
but somehow i'm just tired in a good way
i do kind of wish the pacing of this was
more like how it was in the last the
first two was definitely a different
more controlled pace well i think the
first the last 15 minute 10 to 15
minutes of this episode like when layla
and him are driving and they're talking
and then they go to the sands that
that's when i was like i kind of wish
this was a little bit more of the pacing
for the rest of the episode because they
did jam pack it a lot to the point where
so much was just happening he's chasing
down people we don't know exactly who
they were chasing down for 10 minutes i
thought we accidentally watched the
wrong thing that came back yeah it says
there's a time jump
and then it was like
we're doing a born movie all of a sudden
and and it's so there's it's moving at
such a whiplash pace you have like
everything with arthur herrera going on
and then mark spector and then when they
like oh now we're going to meet the gods
and we're dealing with this trial and it
was just like boom boom boom boom boom
and then now we're doing this like me
this
handsome dude some guys here with the
map i'm like okay this is this is a it's
just it got to the point where i found
myself just paying attention to get
information and i wasn't really
affected by it as much like whereas like
the last two really gave me a lot of
feels but i think the last like 15
20 minutes of this episode really made
up for how i was feeling towards the
first half of this i would have
preferred seven episodes and had that be
like one and a half episodes like i
would have this one
so like i would have preferred the show
been a little longer overall i mean
obviously we don't know how it's going
to land but like that was a lot yeah
just no postcards and i don't post
credit it's it's interesting because i
really loved the first two episodes a
lot and this was like i was usually my
out of the three so far this is easily
the one i would rank third
out of them all but there's still a lot
to appreciate i'd say i don't know each
apology i don't know the history of it
all
my most knowledge comes from indiana
jones and the mummy like and that's all
you need my one year in social studies
where i really paid attention because i
like those movies that's about as far as
it goes i would i movies are important
movies attention and history that might
inspire you to pay attention
cyrus and anubis it was great any
teachers watching at home bring in that
vcr combo yeah and scroll that in so i i
liked getting a lot of that lord history
that's what i mean i think there's a lot
to appreciate there and i think the set
design is really cool the way they've
evolved conch you as well like here was
the first time i really got the sense
that this guy a little bit twisted and
how he's like i really want that lady
you get a sense of actual care from him
in this one especially in that like
those last moments the most consistent
factor that i find really strong is
you know oscar isaac interacting with
oscar isaac that to me is is easily the
strongest one we'll get to like our
theories and speculation on what's going
on a little bit involving leyla and
perhaps the third personality but one i
know we went out of order you're
supposed to be the you're supposed to be
the one that kicks us off
kicks the ball yeah no i mean i i i
agree with your assessment in that this
does feel like they kind of crammed
stuff into like it was all interesting
like it's one of those situations where
for me i was like i was interested in
everything and i was pleased with
everything that we were getting but yeah
i was like this whole you know trial
seems like it ought to be an expanded
sequence or something like that it's
funny because you have so many reasons
to go indiana jones or the mummy and
there are shots that make me think of
that but yeah this was much more of sort
of like a you know foot chase heavy paul
green grassy style thing and i like that
stylistic shift i feel like it's within
the personality of this show and it
lends credence to the whole like we're
gonna go a little more hardcore i i'm a
little bit distracted when it is like
yeah they're throwing down on harsher
choreography that still has no blood in
it yeah
you know so there is we can have blood
as long as it's a cut to
the blood come out it's weird it was
more effective to me in the first
episode when you have uh stephen black
out and then come back with the blood
all over the uh
yeah and it's like you know obviously
the trade-off is you get the blood
because you don't get the violence in
that situation but you know i mean
that's just a little thing that did kind
of stick out at me as i'm curious to see
how the mcu going forward especially in
these shows will bridge that gap because
i don't think they've fully managed it
here the character stuff
uh was really great and from the last
episode i remember us being like i don't
know really what if i wanted to see
behind the curtain of arthur harrow with
you know his sinister intent the way he
drains that homeless guy but i thought
the way they brought it back around with
him in this episode with his scenes like
it brought it back to that place of
authentic pathos that comes from him
that whole monologue he gives at the end
about like you know if this mission i'm
on you know i owe my conviction and you
know the strength and the burden to you
like i thought that brought him back to
a pretty interesting spot and it helped
to alleviate the sort of repetitive
structure that this would have in the
sense that you have mark and layla you
know scrambling to get somewhere and
they do and then hey here comes arthur
harrow and he's pretty chill about it
and he's in control
and that happens you know a few times
but i thought that when they really
settled into scenes that was when the
episode would sing i totally agree with
the arthur harris stuff i'm back to
being 100 interested and immersed in his
character and ethanol is crushing this
very unlikable likable charming like
every action he's doing is impossibly
evil but he's so charismatic and
interesting you're like tell me more
about your weird crazy girl so that's
like really impressive work and also i
don't know have ever seen
work with a did study quite like what
oscar isaac's doing because not only do
we see visual transformations with just
like eyebrow use and all those things
from one personality to another but when
he's taken over by khanshu and the voice
of kontru feels like it's bursting out
of him and he's like getting exhausted
by like being overwhelmed by this voice
that's another complete entity and
another complete acting style the work
in this is insane and laila we got that
whole opening scene where we hadn't
really had a lot of time with layla
one-on-one it was really smart to open
with that endear us to her that way
we're more invested in their
relationship throughout this episode so
if you only know mark and stephen you
don't really worry about leila's
relationship by the end we're like man
layla's falling for steven and falling
out of love with mark at the same time
and now we care about leila because of
that one eight-minute scene so the
structure worked for me but if this
episode was an hour and a half or if
this was spread across two i would have
preferred it just because i do feel like
when you eat a sandwich that has too
many toppings some bites are more
delicious than others and there were
moments in this that felt like a too
salty bite and i wanted the bites to be
spread out it's a really great sort of
great medicine
in this moment that's like a perfect
matter yeah that's right this episode
too many too many toppings my sandwich
yeah also i'm hungry i'm sure there's
going to be a lot of temperature hungry
i'm sure there's a lot of people who
probably like really
other people like this is their favorite
and it's totally fine yeah i think
there's a lot to appreciate i think the
action was cool i i prefer more of the
close-ups on moon knight when he's
fighting because sometimes he's moving
about way too fast for me like when he
got to the roof i'm like what the [ __ ]
he was just there
like a second ago i also think this
would have been a really hard script to
direct because i imagine muhammad looked
at the script and went okay we're gonna
cover this today
the sheer volume of what this episode
needed to do because we haven't seen any
shooting conversation
and like we haven't seen where this goes
and what they had to connect from blank
to blank to but i can't imagine this was
not not intimidating no so like it's a
really impressive feat from the actor's
standpoint director's standpoint
production design standpoint costume
design standpoint one of my favorite
scenes of this whole series so far is
what they just did at the end with
konchu and mr knight literally going
back through time but i can't imagine
looking at the script starting with
layla and ending with that being like
this is an episode of television it
feels like it was also quite the bite to
take when looking at a six episode
series which makes me really intrigued
what four five and six are because if
this was two three what is the rest of
the show i haven't lost faith in it
because normally with these shows i'm
like okay episode one and two were kind
of slow but three's when it gets good
yeah so it's kind of an interesting
effect when you're like yeah through is
okay but one and two regret so it's like
it makes you still like heavily invested
i'm like a a b plus so far like it's
still high for me but it was just a
slight and that was just overwhelm which
a lot of people also like this is gonna
i mean i'm sorry to us but we're a
little older like maybe there's the next
generation who's more of the tick tock
mindset where they're like just gonna
need stimulants
i need more at all
there's a very plausible reason that
like disney making a show that's this
dense might have felt the compulsion you
have this much in an episode because a
lot of people are on their phones when
they watch tv a lot of people are
scrolling a lot of people you can't with
this episode so maybe there is something
to like when we look back at 60s and 70s
movies the pacing is like watching paint
dry for me 80 of the time i struggle
this might be us just getting old and
this is the new standard and we're just
seeing it and feeling like overwhelmed
for the first time like i don't know
what the standard operating procedure
for content and
like amount in in time is gonna be in
five years but it could just be like
world
yeah maybe koi
that's maybe that's what it is
i'm saying younger people might enjoy it
more but it's still a b-plus for me
personally it's still like one of the
better marvel shows i think with the
fighting it was interesting i like the
close-ups on it more because that's when
it looked the more
real practical yeah there were parts of
it i'm like oh that does feel like ben
affleck in the warehouse fight in
certain shots certain moments when he is
pounding on them sometimes though i am
curious why some shots of moon knights
of outfit there are some shots where i'm
like i get why that part looks cgi but
why does this other part look cgi and so
i don't really understand the mechanics
i know they do these like behind the
scenes on their disney plus shows i'm
curious to know why some shots are like
so overtly cgi when i would when i
doesn't i feel like
doesn't feel like it necessitates it but
i and it pulls me out because i feel
like with concho they've like mastered
how to do kanchu in like broad daylight
or at night they know how to really like
mask him shadow him in to the point
where it looks so good and even like the
last effects you know with the with the
stars and stuff i thought it was
beautiful the ball that looked like
straight out of the comic it was amazing
to look at mr knight always looks
fantastic
but then moon night sometimes i'm going
why does he look so computer at times
when i he doesn't seem like he needs to
i like the fight a lot it definitely
like you said more stabby stabby than
most of them stabbing
stabbing there we go we've seen
thousands of fights i've never seen a
horse spike fight
so i like having a new style of fight
because the comics are able to do so
many different also also it didn't even
this is the highlight of the episode for
me and it's a silly small thing but
because of my comic book love they did
the thing here that eternals failed that
you guys know i love eternals i saw you
i knew it was coming up in eternals they
made a movie that felt removed from the
mcu but had to go like remember same to
you with a couple lines of dialogue that
for me felt forced and actually like
took me out instead of in this mentions
a location within the mcu in a in a
context that makes sense and it goes hey
we're going to keep this very unique
tone the show feels nothing like a lot
of the mcu but because the word mad
report in a sentence that fits in
context is said in the comics that would
that would have been bold like you would
have just felt that little like
connectivity and therefore this feels
like the comic version of a shared
universe more than the mcu the mcu feels
like the movie shared universe this
feels like reading a comic and hearing
like oh i get it and then flip the page
like i thought that was the perfect
delivery for madrid for the mcu at home
you know in the last episode there was a
book that was that had asgard on it and
wakanda you know in the first episode
when they hit that bus the bus had the
grc on it which is the uh thing they
mentioned about like monitoring stuff in
uh phase four
little details but magic is
yeah you know what i think that what
what my the reason why the emotional
effect in my mind felt like it was
moving too fast there was a lot of new
characters in this episode
you know yeah absolutely like it feels
like a new setup that's like did i miss
something
and i was like replaying the previous
thing on my head like no that's where i
left off like it's just like did i miss
something in a week yeah that is a good
point because it didn't hit me at the
time and this episode gave me part of
what i was hoping for last time which
was okay now we're gonna do the mark
with stephen breaking through episode
and yeah
it didn't hit me until now but you are
dealing with so many new places and
people the whole time to quickly touch
back on that thing that you said about
the fighting i think that too goes
against the theory that this is all in
his head or that there's some kind of
alternate reality that we're
experiencing here because the more he
teleports around and the more other
people acknowledge that the more it
feels like and even things like the
jackal or her being aware of the suit it
seems like this is a tangible thing that
is actually magical and is actually
happening it hit me during this
uh that this has two themes that are
like really
kind of cyclical throughout the mcu so
even though it's not like reference
heavy it is dealing with how do we
handle preventative crime fighting and
also god's not wanting to interfere with
the follies and squabbles of man those
converge here in a really heavy way and
it's like we had that in civil war with
the whole you know like eyes in the sky
kind of thing and we've i'm watching the
shield season seven right now that's all
about the past and hey should we take
the shot in the past if it means
preventing blah blah blah in the future
like there's so much about preventative
crime in the mcu and i'm now also
waiting for them to take that one step
further because we have this format to
do that in and i thought you know there
were some good arguments toward that
within this episode uh on display and
that was some of the strongest stuff
they did here we don't often talk about
the macro of our world in relation to
the mcu but bringing up preventative
crime and something i've been thinking
about a lot in our fiction is obviously
we're living in an age of like needing
the moral compass of heroes and our
fiction because our world feels like
it's crumbling at all times and we're
seeing as we get older more and more
evil go unchecked and all of her
governments and all of her formats
aren't actually doing any of the things
that we were raised to think they were
to do
but we're entering the age of like
recording everything in a very orwellian
sense we literally film everything to
the point where there's going to be a
time when the 90s and 80s and earlier
are going to be considered prehistoric
because there isn't going to be an
objectivity like i'm sorry a
subjectivity everything is going to be
an objectivity everything is going to be
recorded so it's going to be like this
is true this is not but then very soon
thereafter there's going to be a level
of deep fakes and a level of unreality
where we're not going gonna actually
know what is real on record or not
because we're already getting deep fake
visual and voices that are almost
photorealistic so we're gonna have this
short window where objectivity is gonna
take over and what's that gonna look
like with preventative prime when
everything is so
point shoot true false and what is that
gray scale of morality going to be
versus law because so many laws are so
updated with the current structure of
reality that's a great philosophical
point because marvel addresses that in
each of their films like we're saying
but we don't look at that in our day to
day like we don't reflect that as much
but this show doing that through
something so elevated as egyptian gods
from historic times it's really
interesting to look at how you feel
about certain things how you feel about
harrow how you feel about mark how you
feel about stephen in relation how it
affects your day-to-day life of what you
perceive these laws and realities and
rules as that make any sense get that
all from from this one episode just i
got that all from life
from life
that is a great like societal point of
view i think at its core with the mcu
and this show in particular really
focuses on what its characters is about
self-acceptance that's probably the top
theme i think like this whole thing with
mark and stephen is there at odds with
one another and mark clearly doesn't
like himself and feels ashamed steven
feeling like he's not good enough and if
you look at all our other characters in
the mcu a lot of times their arc is
learning to be like you know what i am
enough i can do this from me yeah
whatever my affliction might be is
actually also part of my strength yeah
and that's so comic book-y like that's
one of the things i like about comic
books is your weakness is often your
strength and the things that make you
unique or the thing that makes you
strong and i mean and i think in all of
our lives once we accepted more of our
weird [ __ ] we became better at our jobs
and our lives and our personal lives and
our relationships and i think that the
marvel characters are very good at going
like hey x-men what makes you a freak is
your strength hey spider-man that like
bubble ball and i think moon knight
accepting that steven is the strength in
some circumstances and mark is the
strength in others when mark literally
kills people in steven's little dweeb
those strengths are really incredible to
have with two characters competing for a
body i do gotta say steven did kind of
annoy me a little bit when
mark was fighting off those yeah
yeah that steven was like interfering
yeah let go and i'm like dude what are
you doing there's the one time i got i
know some people are back and forth that
stephen oh is he an annoying character
or not a lot of people actually like
fight about that i've seen in the
comments i don't find him annoying i
like him a lot i love him i actually
like him more than mark i think he's a
much more amusing personality than mark
like mark is i don't know getting more
mark in this episode i enjoyed him i
think oscar isaac does a great job but
let's face it just care his portrayal is
like it's a little bit more
straightforward yeah it's about what
you'd expect from her that's a hammer
and and steven's uh more of a fine-tooth
comb like they're different skill sets
no yeah a thousand percent i think
that's what works best with mark is when
he's interacting with stephen is the
complement of the personalities right
that's why i love those scenes so much
is because of that but when you don't
have like mark really interacting with
steven or konshu for that matter i don't
find mark anywhere near as engaging as i
do find steven particularly although
whenever he is donning moon done i'm
like hell yeah let's go moon night
that's great now we gotta talk really
quick a couple of theories and i want to
turn off the video now in case just a
couple of theories here one jake
locklead a cab driver personality who's
more of like the guy on the st it would
stand to reason that it could be jake
lockery as that third personality jake
lockley is more of like the dude who
goes on the streets gathers information
and whatnot you know walks amongst the
people
and so i could see him being like yeah
he's he's out and about and this is like
in the daylight because i was like a
little bit stricken by oh wow mark's
just out there in the date like messing
people up on rooftops right now okay
cool so i could see it being jake
lockley i think jake might be our lead
for the last third i think jake might
come in at the that'd be surprising well
think about how like we talked about how
she doesn't really know mark steven
doesn't feel like he has a lot of
history we don't know the stuff of the
steven and his mom and the later gators
stuff all those things and then these
blips first introduce the idea of there
being someone else what if these two are
in jake's head true it's interesting
because mark brought up a point about
like i thought i was fine for like the
last few years but only recently i
started breaking so it seems like mark
has been aware of his other
personalities for a while
which would be comic accurate but then
he suppressed them to the point where
they forgot yeah or like or like steven
grant forgot about mark and what's time
perception when you're trapped in the
mirror and like how long is anything for
another personality so i think that
could be the case with layla it seems
like that she would be the daughter of
because
in the comic around the time before
mark's when mark smacker's just
mercenary
and then there's a guy
and the lemire small would run they
paint him to look like sam neil
from jurassic park he gets killed i
don't think that character was layla but
i think they would
adopt her to be here that would probably
be why yeah mark is like i feel guilty
shut up maybe she doesn't know he was
involved yeah i think he killed sam neil
you think so yeah i think mark killed
her dad i think i feel like you'd be on
the same mission but maybe i think he
killed him i think that's what harrow's
holding i think harrah knows or or he's
would they go that far
or maybe he's somehow responsible in
in a
direct way or or maybe he wasn't able to
save him or something like that i do
think that's what i'm saying he was part
of he was like they're what it happened
i feel like it would be in the mask i
feel like it would be an interesting
challenge if they actually let him be
the one who did it because then what
would the conversation be about her
loving stephen and not mark yeah because
mark killed her dad but steven didn't
same body though how do you forgive the
body of a man
that's a there's a philly
question
if you've got multiple personalities
people who date people with the idea
yeah like i said polyamory
gets complex you know you're polyamory
in a one-stop shop
mark specter stephen grant blockley
they're different too like they'd be
like a gentle lover and mark would
probably be more aggressive one might be
subservient it might be a dom they
probably have different kinks you know
that body is you would be like oh i
don't know what to do right now
i think stephen has got all that geeky
like stamina and mark's got too much
ptsd where he's actually the struggle i
think stephen better than mark and no
but jake jake cleans them oh jake
handles this jake's man
oh yeah he knows what he's doing that's
why you need jake the second third of
the show third of the show
the second half of the show should be
like eyes wide shut in egypt
gotta send this to disney let them know
what we want make it happen
you know when you're tired and i'm tired
we perform at two very different energy
levels it's fascinating
you're still remarkably sharp
i go up and up in order to not fall
asleep it's impressive i wish i had some
food here guys sandwiches overstuffed
what'd you think leave your thoughts
down below
hey we'll catch you guys soon check us
out patreon